remember that playstation event that was
supposed to happen last week well it's
actually happening this week also EA's
got its first-ever cross-platform game
coming tomorrow and twitch streamers are
being flooded with copyright claims I'm
Kurt Davina and this is safe state for
Monday June 8 if the stars align and the
universe allows it PlayStation is going
to be having at the big ole event this
Thursday on June 11th at 1:00 p.m. Pt
and 4 p.m. ET and this was confirmed by
Cena now it's gonna be focused on games
but PlayStation plans to have a bunch of
announcements leading up to the PS 5s
launched in the fall in regards to last
week's event being delayed CEO Jim Ryan
said it was no time to celebrate in
churn Sony's PlayStation Division
pledged 1 million dollars to the black
community buckle up because EAS got its
first cross-platform game hitting
tomorrow and it's need for speed heat
thus the buckle up joke yeah this patch
marks its final update and we'll
introduce cross play for heat across all
platforms ps4 Xbox one and PC making it
the first game from EA to offer the
feature tomorrow players are gonna be
asked whether or not to opt into the
feature now of course you don't need to
case you don't want to play with others
that's fine but it's cool that the
option is there twitch streamers are
being flooded with copyright claims for
their past clips recent surge of DMCA
takedown requests have overwhelmed the
community twitch support staff has
responded to complaints stating the
claims are focused on clips with
background music from 2017 to 2019 and
recommending that streamers remove them
advocates like Ryan Morrison better
known as the video game attorney advised
content creators not to counter the
claims without speaking to an
intellectual property lawyer saying in
the tweets you are quite literally
telling them you are going to continue
what you're doing unless they sue you
don't threaten billionaire companies to
sue you lawyer up Morrison noted that
twitch did not change their policies
instead it appears that it's merely
being enforced in a meaningful way for
the first time on the platform okay
that's it for news but just as a
reminder games
Mott's got played for all and multi week
event raising money for both black lives
matter and those fighting on the front
lines of cove in nineteen every single
day from 12 p.m. to 2 p.m. Pt we're
having charity streams raising money for
both those causes and they're gonna be
featuring loads and loads of special
guests alongside that we're gonna have a
ton of exclusive content for game
announcements and a bunch of other jazz
so come back there's gonna be links to
that stuff and information in the
description below ok that's it for
today's safe State I'm Kurt Davina come
back tomorrow come back Wednesday come
back Thursday that's one safe stay
happens Monday through Thursday yeah
okay be well wash your hands all that
jazz okay I gotta go
see ya
you
[Music]